Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 3rd, 2017 what's going on? how are you ?
how's it go? A little white guy. DEF Jam Voice.
Little White Guy. Jam Voice. I'd taken you back through a little comedy history.
Remember that the height of black guys do these white guys do that and was
always [inaudible] to have, I'd have to have that fucking voice.
You ever see a white gas stated a chair or sit in a chair?
Oh, I'm a black guy. When he sits in the chase, it's in the mother fucker.
GM white guys did odd years. I set out, I actually, I did my taxes.
Every fucking joke crushed.
Fucking crushed. That was the black comic version of white guys.
Go and talking about flying on airplanes, comparing dogs to cats.
That's more like it. You know, dogs. You Fran a cat. Huh? Don't even fucking,
you know, that's actually still not a complimentary voice for a white guy.
But I don't think that was a complimentary voice for a black guy.
So I think I'm in the clear when it comes to political correctness.
Um, oh my God, what a fucking weekend I had, man. I had a great time.
You know, I had a great time.
I watched the fucking Bruins pick up four points this weekend. All right.
And put themselves back into the driver's seat at least of their own destiny.
All right. By Beaton, the Florida fucking path.
And thank God the Chicago Blackhawks had the decency to rest.
Most of the good guys in their team. A, we will pick up another two points.
So thank you to the city of Chicago. I'm next deep dish is on me.
If I run into you, not the whole fucking city. Just one of you.
Fatties what are you most stash? Yoed fatties from that SNL sketch.
I don't think I've ever seen a guy with a mustache in Chicago, you know? Um,
anyways, I never heard one say dap bears. Never heard that,
never heard it. Um, although I don't talk to a lot of them,
I just kinda go there and stand in front of their performing and then I leave.
That's basically what I do, which is one of my favorite things to fucking do.
By the way, there's nothing,
there's nothing better than when you do your show this second to do it.
You get in a car and you get the fuck outta there.
That's my favorite thing to do, you know,
either that or go to a dive bar and hang out like with three people.
That's the way I'm fucking wired. Um,
that's perfect. Be honest with you.
There's certain people they like to hang out, you know what I mean?
Go Wade into the crowd, you know, continue,
continue to say how awesome I am. I don't do that. I got it for that hour.
Perfect. Then you get in the car and it's nice and quiet. It's quiet.
It just fucking ride home, you know, and you go into your fucking hotel room,
Mike, sit down. You'll avoid the fucking snack buy. Right.
And uh, and then that's it.
You just sit there and the loneliness of your room.
Okay.
That's most reason why I drink on the road, to be honest with you.
That's all you're doing is you just trying to stay out. As long as you can see,
you're so fucking tired that when you get back to your room,
you just immediately fall asleep rather than dealing with the fucking loneliness
of it. But, um, I dunno, I had such a great weekend man.
I played a little bit of drums, hung out with my beautiful daughter.
You know, she's a riot. She bossy as hell.
Oh my God.
She's already telling us what to do with just like the noises that she knows how
to make. Um, yeah,
she's going to be a little smarty just like my wife and she's fucking adorable
as hell. Obviously. You know, I'm a little bias, but a, that's kind of,
you know, you know when people are lying, you know,
if you kid oh hey wa what acuity?
Yes.
I feel like we're getting like legit compliments. So anyways,
can anybody out there in the hockey world explained to me
like, uh, how this, like what seed you are,
works in the playoff bracket. Like,
I don't get it cause um,
it used to be like the Adams Division in the Patrick Division in one played for,
and then they sort of jumbled them all up.
It seems like when they list them as far as like I don't get when you go to the
stand extinct because I would have thought is as a sixth or seventh c whatever
the fuck we're going to be, we'd either play the capitals or the blue jackets,
you know, the top of that one.
But they kind of doing like a march madness thing where it's like we're in like
a different thing.
So for some reason we'd get off easy or I should say and have to play the maple
leafs rather than getting the old right there.
Fred from the capitols of the blue jacket,
not saying that we're going to beat Toronto,
I have no idea what's going to happen.
But according to the Stanley Cup playoffs here on,
on a nhl.com, um, as of today,
the Mario Canadians with Clode,
Julia Julian would play fucking the New York Rangers.
So they're a number one seed and then they would get the wild card,
New York Rangers,
and then the Bruins would play the maple leafs little original six action they
have for you on those. Both of those, Huh.
Then the capitals would play Ottawa and Pittsburgh plays Columbus,
like Pittsburgh gets punished.
Shouldn't they be playing an easier fucking team with the points they have?
I would think what? I'm the bottom faders, so that's great. I love that.
Pittsburgh or the Columbus, we'll knock each other out.
We'll knock one or the other route I should say. And A, I don't know.
I don't know what's going to cause are the capital's finally going to push
through the shift? Is it finally gonna Happen? You know, you know,
it'd be the fucking Armageddon finals would be the Washington capitols versus
San Jose Sharks, you know, can,
one of them has to win, right? Like the cubs verse, the Indians,
somebodies a fucking win. And I bet it would go down the exact same way.
One would go up three to one. You know,
they just got to add that last bit of misery and then someone would come back
and win it. I Dunno. I Dunno what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I know is I really enjoyed, um,
obviously this weekend and if we can play the Tampa Bay lightning on Tuesday and
fucking put them out of their goddamn misery, um,
I think we would avoid three years in a row of, uh, you know,
eaten a dick at the end of March at the beginning of April.
We've done it two years in a row. So, uh, that's it.
That's it for the fucking hockey talk. Oh, by the way,
I don't know what his name is, but that kid on Calgary, uh,
I keep to chuck his kid out there. That kid's a fucking riot, man.
He is an old school hockey player. I was watching a,
what did they have there with the fucking, uh,
Don Cherry hockey night in Canada. We actually get that down here.
And he was showing a highlight of that kid, you know,
picking on that dude from the fucking kinks at Don Cherry's break at his fucking
balls. And it's just like they trying to make the playoffs.
He's not going to get involved with some stupid fucking fight. Right. They,
they true dowdy and he, they need them on the ice, I would think anyways,
to daddy, the Dave Grohl of fucking, uh,
of hockey to me that the,
the exact same fucking person when Dave girls not making amazing music,
he's playing defense for the Los Angeles kings. I challenge you,
I challenge you to find Dave girl ever at a fucking game where, where,
where drew dowdy is not as a healthy scratch. Um, all right,
enough of that bullshit. Um,
I can't even tell to you about my fucking weekend some of this other bullshit.
Oh my God. Hello. If I hang out with just like a complete fucking psychopath,
ugh, just one of those social events you like. Oh No,
there he is. There he is. Um,
and then it's over and then it's the next day and like, oh great. You know,
God willing, I'll never have to see that person again.
Hey, how the fuck are the Celtics said number one seat.
I didn't watch in the last two weeks. I kinda got, you know, you know,
foot fucking hockey and basketball. You kinda got like pick a sport. You know,
I've been, you know, I've been trying to watch both of them, but um, the,
the Bruins were just in a more, uh, you know, I dunno.
Precarious position. So it was more of a exciting thing to watch.
Are they gonna fuck this up?
Are they going to somehow pull themselves out of it? And uh,
some other Celtics or a number one seed,
although I don't think there are a better team than the Cavaliers, but a,
I like what Lebron did the other night last night when he got into it on the
court and that made that other dude on his own team flipping out,
yelling at him and shit.
He immediately tried to diffuse it and then was just saying, yeah,
I showed him up. I shouldn't have said that. Blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I was like, that's a fucking right there.
Even though a of people don't like them. I fucking like Lebron. Um,
so anyways, dude, I've just been having like,
okay,
I know I got to get back into fucking meditating. I don't know,
I've just keep running into these situations. Like I feel like I'm,
I'm attracting the, to me, like somebody,
this New York number has been calling me for like the last fucking three days,
and then I'm like, I don't know who this number is so I don't answer.
And then they finally leave a message to say, Yay, it's just show and show.
You know, I'm looking for show and show, but it keeps saying, ah, you know,
this is bill. Uh, all the time, the thing, but my phone is saying, you know,
it's my daughter. So I'm like,
all right, well this guy is going gonna figure this shit out. Right.
And he does it. So he filed right before he did the podcast,
he fucking calls against. So I finally picked up, I go, hello? The guy's like,
yeah, we'll always just sit. I'm talking to, I'm like, well,
it's not who you'd think it is. Yeah, you got the wrong number. And he goes,
yeah, well fuck you too. He hangs up on me like, like it was my fault.
So I just laugh and I'm just like, what the fuck?
Why does this shit keep happening to me? So then he calls back and I'm like,
well, I got to hear what this guy's going to say next, right.
I need a new hour of material. I got to put myself in the line of fire here.
So I picked up, it goes, Yay man. I'm sorry man. I just,
I lost my phone and I keep trying to call my daughter and you know,
my name's bill and it keeps saying, your name's bill and it's,
you gotta see the humor in that, right? I'm like, yeah man. It's, it's a, yeah,
it's a funny situation. Good luck to you with your phone. I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you. Sounded like a nice enough person.
I love that he said, yeah, well fuck you too.
When he still had the fucking nerve to call me back and then just say,
act like it didn't even, he didn't say that.
Maybe it was just joking when he said it. I was just like, I don't fucking know.
So anyways, this past week, so I'm at a social event,
I'm trying to avoid this psycho audience.
I'm sitting right next to me and I'm talking to this guy and for fucking 10
minutes, all of a sudden I can't find my cell phone
and I'm looking for it and I'm looking forward and I'm not bringing it up to
anybody cause I'm thinking like maybe I left it in the car. I Dunno what,
and I realized that this psycho has placed his cell phone exactly right on top
of mine, on the table,
like completely lined up in mine,
has a black case and was kind of dark so I couldn't see it.
And then I had to sit there playing this fucking mind game. Like,
did this guy do this on purpose? Am I over analyzing this thing?
Am I out of my fucking mind? And, uh, I dunno, did it,
the whole thing just struck me as funny
thinking of how my life used to be.
Cause I used to have people like that in my fucking life. You know,
those people that mind fuck you. And then like an hour later, hey, I'm sorry,
I was like that, that fucking beater relationship, you got to get into him.
Ah, yeah.
Which is course how then the evening ends with that bullshit. Oh yeah, let me,
yeah, no. Hey, it's all right. Everything's cool.
And I just walked out of there and just felt like this fucking weight lift off
me. Just be like, I'm never going to see that person again.
I have no fucking desire. That is it.
That is a fucking Rep.
If I've learned anything from hanging out with fucking, uh,
a cop,
I have two good friends of mine that have both half Sicilian and um,
when applied correctly, the Sicilian,
you're dead to me when applied correctly is the greatest fucking,
it just streamlines your life.
Why would you waste another second of your life playing that mental tennis?
What's that like?
You obviously don't connect with this person over and you just walk away and
then that's it. And like today I just woke up,
I was in the greatest fucking mood knowing I'm never going to see that person
again. It's fucking tremendous.
And you know what I think then I created a void.
I created a vacuum in my life because I just let go all of that shit.
And now I got this random guy calling me up on my cell phone looking for his
daughter and then telling me to go fuck myself, you know, I'll take that.
I mean, that's an easy one.
That guy actually sounded like a better fucking person. So anyways, Oh,
you know what? Easter's coming up fucking east.
It comes Peter cottontail hop it dad,
buddy Trey [inaudible] Easter's on its way. Um,
I, uh, I get this week we're going to actually,
at some point we're going to go back to the mall of become a fucking mall
person. I'm, I imagine eventually it's going to a,
it's going to drive me nuts, but, um,
we're going there and we're taking our daughter over it to get a picture with
the Easter bunny. How fucking cute is that?
It's going to be absolutely adorable. I can't wait to do it,
so we just have to calve out some time.
Um,
yeah, I'm already nervous that she's going to get totally fucking freaked out.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
The older you get, the more you look at that. You just realize why.
What is that bizarre ritual, you know? Why would you do that to you? Sorry,
my stomach is grumbling. Yeah. I'm fucking on a massive diet here. Massive diet,
massive diet, cutting out the booze. Except the last night
cutting out the booze, uh, been eaten basically perfectly.
And uh, I'm actually down to a buck 79.
I fight weights between like one 68, one 72. And uh,
I'm going to try and lose two to three pounds for them. You know,
I figured some by mid May, mid May, I ought to be in fight,
in shape and I'm going to try to actually stay in that and continue cause what,
you know,
what I do is I get down to the way they wanted to get down to and then that's
like the end of the movie roll credits and I go back to eat fucking pizza,
beer and all of that shit. And then I slowly get back up again.
And next thing you know,
I'm standing shirtless in a mirror just calling myself every horrible name.
The that I can think of, you know,
tub of fuck something I've never even heard anybody say.
I actually called myself that before I started this diet.
I actually have suits that I can't fit into anymore.
Like I've hit that point in my life and uh,
it's just like I can't, I can't, uh,
I can't be the guy that goes to the fucking dry cleaner to have his suits let
out. You go to the tailor and you just basically saying, listen, the food one,
I quit. I quit. I don't want to fucking do this anymore.
So, um, anyways, I did, uh,
I'd just been doing, I just been doing cardio.
My fucking shoulder's getting better. I can't really lift weights or anything,
so I've just been kinda just stretching, doing cardio in, in, in, uh,
in trying to eat right. I try to eat like from nine to five and then just stop.
Uh, but the other night I was doing that, uh, April foolishness for, uh,
Kevin and being who I want to thank for having me on that.
We did it down at the, uh, the shrine auditorium, um, which is a famous,
um, theater out here. What the fuck's going on?
And they bring it came and think here. I actually went on Wikipedia.
That's what happens. I was trying to look at some of this other shit.
Some of this advertising I have to read.
I literally get like anxiety as I look at it. Like, Oh God,
look how long this fucking copy is.
Don't want to read all that as I'm trying to talk to you guys. My apologies.
I was distracted there.
So I played the shrine auditorium for Kevin and being show, uh,
April foolishness every year that raises money for, um,
I think it's premature babies. I believe that's what it is.
I never know what it is. I always ask right before I go on,
what is this cause for so I can steer clear of going out there like that
show you just let it die or something, you know, just not walking into that.
So we were at the shrine auditorium and I looked, went up on Wikipedia, went up,
I went to it on, uh,
on the Internet there and I found out, uh, that that is the place,
the most legendary thing that I saw that happened at that place.
Aside from like the grateful dead and all these guys doing shows was that was
the place where Michael Jackson's shot the Pepsi commercial and Ed,
his hair lit on fire, his Jerry Curl, you know,
when he was slowly at the beginning.
Was it the beginnings of transforming into a white guy? Um, you know,
I dunno if it was the product he had, if it was a Jerry curl, if it was a conch,
I don't know what he had going on. Okay.
I don't know how that mixes with Pepsi and Flammable Shit,
but all I know is his head lit on fire and um,
he got second degree burns. That was it.
And all these fucking people were like crying. They would terrify,
you know that these tremendous artists, his head caught on fire,
his fucking head caught on fire doing a Pepsi commercial.
There was another groundbreaking thing that he did like,
because back in the day, if you were a,
any sort of a famous person and if you did a commercial,
you would just consider it a complete sellout. Um, at least in the white world.
I don't know how it worked or he kind of was a hybrid though, right?
He treats sort of the first Caitlyn Jenner, but he didn't like in a race way,
you know,
like the way he walked out the door and due to Quebec, a woman,
he walked out the door, a black guy, it came back, a white guy. Um,
I mean,
I can't imagine being friends with that guy every time he would leave and he'd
just come back. He was like a shopaholic, but like for his face,
you know what I mean? You know, he's chicks always come about. Well,
it's coming back when I got a new bag, you know what I mean? Or some fucking,
I dunno what shoes is. Some shit. He would do the same thing, but with his face,
uh, yeah, Bell, he was one of the most famous people ever. We know what he did.
Okay. Anyways, plowing ahead. Um, so I'm,
I get to do that show down at the shrine auditorium and I cannot even begin to
tell you what a fucking great time. I had unbelievable crowd.
Like I had to do a half hour at the end of all these other monsters going out
there, fucking killing it the entire night.
And Steve O did a hilarious fucking stunt, fucking hilarious.
And uh,
I got to go on like at the end of all this shit and do a half hour and it was
fucking effortless. That's how great the crowd was.
So I wanna thank everybody who came out for that wonderful cause that I believe
was for a premature kids.
You guys liked the birds chirping in the background.
Somebody mentioned to me that's fucking hilarious.
Listened to me going off on shit with birds chirping. I usually don't do, uh,
um, do my fucking podcasts in this room.
I just do it cause it's the furthest one away from my daughter's sleeping.
You know, I don't want to hear me dropping all the f-bombs. So anyways,
the end of the show comes right and everybody's shaking hands.
Oh you are great now. You are great. No, I like how your mind works now.
I like how your mind works better. You know,
we're all doing the Hollywood thing, right? Everybody had a good set. And uh,
once again, I ran into one of these crazy fucking parents,
right? This is fucking hilarious. This is what this person did. They said, oh,
congratulations on your daughter. I said, ah, you brought it up.
You brought it up. Now I've got to show you a picture. Right?
So her and her husband is standing there, right? The young young people,
right. They look like they're single. They don't even look like they have kids.
And I just show them the picture and she just goes, uh, yeah.
It's so easy. He see, it's so easy. It's so easy.
She started pointing my kid going, it's so easy. I'm like,
what the fuck is she talking about? I've heard adorable. She's cute. Oh my God.
Look at those cheeks. She's got a, yeah. So it's so easy. Yeah, I see.
You see? It's so easy. I'm like, what do you mean it's so easy? She goes,
she goes, we have three, we have three. It's so hard. You have no idea.
It's so and just,
she used my daughter's picture as a way to launch into how fucking difficult her
life was. First of all, it's like, how fucking difficult is your life?
[inaudible] you look like you've been P90x me.
You guys don't have an ounce of fat on you. You don't have bags under your eyes.
It's Saturday night. You're out at a show me the one of you yawning.
And they were going, yeah,
we had one and then and then we got pregnant again and then we had, we had,
and I was going like, oh, and I'm sitting there trying to be empathetic.
Oh yeah. You know, I hear a,
I hear too is like a game changer and then three, it's like you're out numbered.
She goes, oh no. We went from one right to three like we had, we had,
we had twins next to two kids. Oh,
I don't even know what that feels like. We don't even know what that feels like.
It's just like, you know what? You don't know what?
You don't know what it's like to be in a fucking log cabin with no fucking heat.
Like they had 200 years ago. It's fucking hard to the fuck outta here.
I swear to God like I and people like that. It's just,
I just feel bad for their kids. It's like you have to be,
you gotta be a fucking terrible parent. What kind of person has a kid? Right.
And all I do when I see other people's kids is I just think of how much that
person must love that kid.
They have to feel the same way that I do about my kid.
And then I'm happy for them.
Who the fuck looks at somebody else's kid and just and compares like, Oh,
it's so, it's so easy. Yeah. See Etsy
and then I go, yeah, you know what?
We're thinking of having another one and then, then the guy goes, yeah,
just have one gone out to war. First of all, like you can control it. Oh,
they drive me up the fucking wall. I fucking, I'm going to say it.
I fucking hate parents. Generally speaking, I cannot stand them. They like,
they're like fucking martyrs. They like these fuckers. He's like,
you put yourself in this situation. Shut the fuck up.
You have three people that are going to be sad when you die.
They're actually going to give a shit and they're going to show up and say how
great you are at where it isn't that enough. It's so hard.
You have no really with iPads in fucking 200 channels of cable,
you can put them in front of a fucking plasma TV. It's like looking into a, a,
a tropical fish tank all day for them. You know they're soft.
You know what I mean? I don't know. I just, Oh God,
there's so many times in my life like I wish I could just go back like that.
I'm doing you believe it or not. I'm great in the moment on stage.
I'm so bad at it when I'm off stage. You know what I mean? I'm just, you know,
cause I immediately just get to this anger level and then I ended up looking
like a psycho. Like I wish I just said that to him.
Like you guys sound like terrible parents.
Do you want to put your kids up for adoption?
So maybe you can go back to doing blow or whatever the fuck it is that you miss.
Do you go back in?
Wish I could go back to last night and just tap that guy on his shoulder and
just pointed his cell phone on top of mine and just be like, yeah,
on a psychological level, would you like to explain this to me?
How did this happen? Was this by accident? But I don't,
I don't fucking say anything.
And then I just fucking write people off and then they look at me like I'm out
of my mind, which I am. I'm definitely out of my mind,
but I'll tell you right now, I'm not the only one. I am not the only one.
And I've learned that. I learned that this weekend. Oh,
so you see it's so easy. It's so, it's like,
why would you say you don't have any fucking idea?
Imagine if I had a special needs kid. Then you've pointed at Saint,
it's so easy. What the fuck is wrong with you? Oh, that's right.
You're completely self involved. Ah, ah.
It felt good to get this out. Oh Jesus.
I'm glad I didn't say I'm glad I saved the for the podcast,
but wouldn't the podcast be better if I actually started saying these things to
people? So then I would have the confrontations and I could just,
maybe I could then do a two hour podcast. Hey, who knows?
Who knows? So, you know, I, as I mentioned earlier,
I are the last podcast I got, um,
I finally got Sirius Satellite Radio on my car,
so I'm fucking listening to the 80s channel, the 70s channel NHL.
You know, I listen to opie show, Jim Norton's fucking show.
And I finally listened to Howard Stern for the first time and fucking forever.
And um,
he had Craig Ferguson on and Craig Ferguson was going on and on about the
Chappelle fucking special. I gotta check it out. He was going on and on.
It might be that greatest one I've ever seen. I'm like, well, fuck,
I gotta check that out. I gotta fucking check that one out.
But half of me does not want to watch it cause I know it's going to be,
I don't want to feel like, oh my God, uh,
certain people you watch to get inspired, I can't want you to shit.
Cause it'd be like, Oh God, I suck.
Really the gap is still that large, you know,
I don't know. Every once you know,
every once in a while you think you're fucking Hendrickson,
then you realize you just playing a Ukulele. Right. Isn't that what happens?
Isn't that what life is? Anyways? Let me, uh,
let me read a little bit of the advertising here. Uh,
it's unbelievable. It's the greatest special I've ever seen.
I was just like Jesus Christ. Alright. Proflowers everybody. Um,
have you ever forgotten your anniversary? Uh, yeah.
To be honest with you right now I would, if you asked me, I would be,
I'm 80% sure of my anniversary date,
but fortunately I'm married a person who also, we don't, we can never,
uh, we don't really remember the day that we met.
We don't have a day for that. And we, like this year we were like,
what's, what's our wedding date again? See 11th Right? No,
12th no. 11th 11. 11th. Yeah, it's 11.
Um, but if, I don't know if you married some, I don't know, accountants.
If you married an insecure accountant, they know what the date is. Right.
Have you ever gotten your anniversary? If you're nodding yes, you're lying.
Well, how do you figure that,
you know those people that are just hard to shop for?
Yeah.
Wait, what the fuck state, if you, have you ever forgotten your anniversary?
If you're nodding yes, you're lying. Well, I wasn't nodding, but I have,
I've actually booked myself on my anniversary weekend because I forgot.
I just don't think that, I just think, oh,
every other week I go on the road and if it lands on that week,
then I wasn't out and it just, you know,
okay.
I don't know. Evidently pro flowers, I don't know Jesus.
Are they fucking psychos?
Are they going to put this cell phone on top of my cell phone anyway?
She know those people that are just hard to shop for like your wife or your
anniversary or your sister for her birthday. It's just the worst. Trying to fit.
Find to find a gift that that a, you know,
they'll like and be won't cost an arm and a leg.
All right? First of all, that's what the fuck they want.
They want something that they gonna like and they also want something that's
going to cost an arm and a leg pro flowers stop acting like this is like a
substitute for a gift. All right? You are the fucking appetizer.
This is a great appetizer getting flowers,
but if you think you'd get a fucking every year just to get your wife flowers.
Hey Tom, thanks for hanging in there. Nursing the baby. Oh,
you shove these in your face and give them a whiff.
I'm going to throw them in and face. There'll be dead in two days.
This cost me 29 bucks. That's how I feel for you.
This is what you get as an alcohol draw mall to whatever the fuck else you going
to get. Right? A condiment.
This is the mustard on top of the hot dog that costs like fucking, you know,
whatever it is. You make like a good 40% of your salary salary, right?
Salary. Salary. All right, well I'm going to make it easy for you.
Pro Flowers is my go to for flowers. It isn't.
There's a guy down the street that sells on me, puts them together. Great.
It's a person and I like them, but you know,
if I'm sitting in a cubicle and I don't have time for this shit,
I'm going to pro flowers. All right?
They're fresh priced right in our perf or the perfect gift for literally anyone
and they, yeah, get one for one of your buddies.
I'm sure I'll love them and they get delivered straight to your recipient's
door. How easy is that? And that's what women don't like.
He didn't put any fucking thought in this whatsoever.
That's why it's in a cool drawable right now.
Pro Flowers has a special offer for just our listeners.
Get $10 off your purchase of $29 or more.
Pro Flower bouquets are bouquets police.
Our police are guaranteed fresh for seven days or your money back.
They have a seven step quality check,
which means the flowers are always awesome.
Their website is super easy to use.
You can schedule your delivery ahead of time for any date you want and get back,
get back to yellow fucking day.
Pro Flowers is a no brainer gift for a birthday,
which is why you have to get it.
Also get her something else and anniversary every occasion or even for no
occasion in all. Anytime when you want her to feel special,
they take care of all the details. Yeah. Pro Flowers is great for date.
If you're going to add it to a gift or if it's not a special day and you just
get it for them, that's a fucking great thing.
You know like if this seven days out of the year, you know,
fucking their birthday, your anniversary, Valentine's Day,
that fucking bird in the tree flag day.
Okay.
This is when you get them kicking around like fucking, you know, July 18th.
I was just thinking of you. Those fucking birds are crazy, huh? Uh, anyways,
I know you have either a birthday or your anniversary coming up.
So right now get $10 off your purchase of $20 $29 a more it pro flowers,
but this deal definitely will not last long.
Just go to pro flowers.com and enter code bar at checkout to get the special
deal. All right, there you go. Uh,
look who's de Mian days bought a boat. Boat. Me undies,
me undies. Get you broad.
Some fucking flowers do to do to me on days me on these washy balls in the
showers there. Spell really nice rub the roses. Autumn.
She'll fucking come over and say why did you do that?
Why did you squat in the fucking vase show? Cause I'm,
I wanna sit on your face with my me undies. Sorry.
That one was all over the place.
Elevate your underwear game to the next level with me undies. Your PR, your,
you perfected your wardrobe. But what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs. I have something that will change your life for the bat.
Me undies. Once the first thing you put on and the last thing you take off.
We all know what she had, but this isn't about that. It's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me on these.
What is me on these you might be asking at your cubicle.
Oh, just seriously soft. Feel good undies delivered right to your fucking door.
B undies are designed in Los Angeles or Louisiana. I have no idea.
La and made from sustainably, sustainably sourced, micro modal,
modal, a fabric, three times softer than cotton.
And if you're not ready for it, that's fucking hilarious.
She balls are going to be so fucking cushioned, right?
Compared to the callous hands. I'm kidding.
They're made here by union workers and if you're not ready for a subscription,
that's hey, no pressure. You can still save.
That's because me undies is offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar [inaudible] dot com slash burn and we got
two more and these are quick reads and I love it. All right.
Do Ali Shave Club?
Do buying a fucking raises like buying a cat to smoke?
Get to get smooth luxury quality.
You have to pay a huge price and that means you pay in mostly for splashy
marketing features.
You don't actually need switched to dollar shave club.com everybody.
It's the smarter choice, luxury quality and an economy price.
Dollar Shave clubs raises are amazing quality.
They've got the shave tech you need and none of the overprice gimmicky shit.
You don't. Alright, have you seen the,
they add for the raises monopolies newest raise a thing.
It has like 21 blades. Swivel pivot fucking robot.
Raise it with the laser pointer to your chin.
Every year they make a tiny changes arrangement. They do that,
they change it a little bit and then the new fucking blades don't fit it.
And then you've got to keep up with the Joneses. It's complete boys' bullshit.
All right, you want to get out of it?
Join Dollar Shave Club and be done with all of that ship.
There's never been a better time to give them a shot.
Right now you can get your first month of any of their amazing razors for only a
buck, including free shipping and after that it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no longterm commitment, no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever the fuck you want.
Get your first month for just the Bucket Dollar Shave
club.com/burn that's dollar shave club.com and lastly,
but not lunch leastly stamps.com you know what?
I use stamps.com whenever I'm sending out any of my posters,
when I feel like I'm going to whore myself out at the end of the shows,
trying to just ring every last dollar out of my fucking fan base. All right,
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use their fucking scale and stamp machine
. So can you stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business. I can mail any letter,
any package using my just my computer and printer and the mailman comes and
picks it up. Avoid the hassle,
man of the post office and mail everything from postcards to stamps to envelope,
sorry to packages domestic or international stamps.com we'll even help you
decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to at least an expense lease, an expensive postage meter right now.
You can enjoy the stamps service with a special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstampsdotcomenterbarstamps.com
never go to the post office again. All right.
Anyways, a I bought the fucking, uh,
the Patriots mate might be talking to Adrian Peterson. Huh? If you're a fucking,
I don't know if you watching the patriots for a long time.
Doesn't that remind you when we signed Corey Dillon?
That'd be nice to get that fucking guy wouldn't maybe see Tom Brady get number
six, right? Somebody said,
he said he wanted to play for another five or six years.
That's fucking unbelievable. Um,
just the fact that he's going to do that means he's going to play for at least
another three. So he's Geek has a legitimate shot at getting another ring. Um,
unreal. Unreal. Good Lord. I fucking enjoy that. All right. Because every time,
every, every plays, I always think this could be the last year.
It could be the last fucking year. You know, Belicheck is almost 70 years old.
Brady's going to be 40, you know, and you know, oh,
we're gonna fucking what's going to happen on that franchise when those two
people leave, who knows? Because what's his face?
Robert Craft is three coaching hires. Bill Parcells, Pete Carroll,
Bill Belicheck. He's three for three. Um, alright,
let's read some of these, uh, some of these emails for the week.
Um, girl freaks out. Hey, they are Billy boy George.
Um, it was funny, I never liked him and when I was in the, uh, in the 80s,
you know, it was too homophobic to like that guy. But, uh,
his fucking drum is to shit on the,
do you really wanna Hook me?
Love the fucking drums on that song. Um, anyways,
not sure if you saw this shit.
Some girl freaked out at a yogurt shop in Santa Monica because the couple behind
her kissed each other.
She starts saying that she was being sexually harassed by them doing so it gets
out of control.
The funny thing is that she starts off acting like a hacky liberal,
but then ends acting like a hacky conservatives as she shifted through stages of
emotion. Uh, the Phoenix video tour video look great. Can't wait for San Jose.
Um, yeah. I actually, I watched some of that at first.
I love this woman because I hate people who fuck, I don't hate,
I hate looking at people making out in public. It's fucking gross.
It's fucking gross. You tongued jammed down each other's throats.
You know, it's like you, I don't want to look at,
especially when I'm around food, I totally get what she's saying.
But then she took it too far when she started saying that she was, uh,
that she was being sexually harassed.
What I did love though is I love how the extreme closeup,
when she's yelling into the camera, it reminded me of that movie misery,
you know, with the ladies. Like you can't wait. Whatever the fuck should says.
Was there anything more satisfying in a fucking movie?
When he finally got in the bed and started slamming that bitch,
his head against the floor. Ah, just laying there that powerless.
Do you know in the book she actually cuts his feet off rather than breaking his
goddamn ankles. Um, I gotta be honest with you.
I really think I could have sweet talked my way out of that bed.
I really would have, I would act like I wanted to fuck her. You know,
I would've done that. Right? Yeah.
I would have told him that I was never going to leave her.
I would have built her fucking up until I started to be able to walk around.
Right. And then I would actually am once I could, even with south,
this is how long of a slow play I would go with that woman. I would actually,
I would, after I could walk,
I would stay in a three month relationship with them till she got so fucking
comfortable. Right.
And then one day I'd be making my famous fucking scrambled eggs,
take out a fucking skillet.
That would be it, man. I would,
I would stay in a relationship with that woman until the fucking snow melted,
you know, and I could shake off whatever thing I had to have fucking,
or I could shake that off. I'm German Irish, I could fucking,
I could put that in a box and never think of it again. No Pun intended.
That's what I would've done. He fucked up. You know what I mean?
He actually wrote the real fucking book.
I guess I that's cause I know that she was out of her mind,
but I swear to God I would've fucking,
I would have told her that I love what she did with her hair. All of that thing.
The hardest thing would have been, was not laughing.
The noises that she would have made during intersects, intersects, intercourse,
intersects. Um, anyways. I don't know what that says about me,
but you know, I, that's, that's how I would've got out of it.
I would've just gotten totally like, oh yeah, yeah, the shit beautiful.
Oh my God, this soup is fucking delicious.
And I would've just talked to her and just find out what the exact fucking books
she wanted me to write. And that's exactly what I would've written.
Maybe I hit it with a typewriter, like some sort of symbolism, I don't know.
But at the end of the day, you know,
fucking some pig versus getting both of your fucking ankles broken. I mean,
I don't think there's it, there's really no trade off. Right.
Um, [inaudible]
you probably would need, she's such a fucking lunatic.
She's probably like asexual. You probably don't have to do that, you know,
just laugh at her jokes. I think you would have been all right. Um, anyways,
I just went on a tangent there. Sorry about that. Uh, here we go, girl.
So when he was getting back to that, yeah, I don't like when, uh,
I don't like watching people make out. It's fucking gross. Me,
I hated him with the two things I hate most in movies is when people are fucking
making out and, and,
and people when they're eating in a scene and then fucking making those fucking
noises.
There's nothing worse than watching an actor eat in a scene because most times
they're not eating. So they have to overact eating and everybody,
I don't know what happens. They turn into fucking animals.
They started eating with their mouth open.
They started pointing at people with the bread.
MMM. [inaudible]
that, and I, I hate love scenes in movies. You know what I mean?
Like when they take it to the point where literally one actor is on the other
actors titties, it's just like, I get it. They're going to have sex. Like,
why are you going take it to this? Let whiskey.
Are you making a porno now I want to watch a porn. Oh,
I just want you to fucking porno. Why can't you just have a walk in the bedroom?
And then they closed the door. I get it. They fucked. Like, who is that for
Tay Away?
They're always up against the wall and it's fucking raining out or some shit,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Rather than they're getting used to each other,
figuring out which lip to go for. Do you go for the top lip or the bottom lip?
You know what I mean? What position do you like?
Do you like to have your ass slapped and not all that shit's out of the way.
They just automatically start acting like they've been banging each other the
whole summer. Little bit cold,
whatever fucking songs they play. What are some of the stupid,
the 80s they always played that stupid saxophone.
The saxophone got ruined in the 80s it went from this, like,
it went literally from this instrument that when it was in the hands of a black
person,
it actually scared the CIA to the 80s where it just meant that Tom Cruise was
going to fuck somebody.
You know, half of those jazz guys in the fucking,
from the forties 50s and 60s ad their fucking phones bugged by the Goddamn Jad
go Hoover and the FBI. And then just, it just,
somehow it just all went to shit in the 70s.
It all went to shit and the fucking seventies, you know,
they whacked everybody that they needed to whack in the 60s.
They figured out how not to lose public support of a war after the debacle of
Vietnam. Right? So now they've got everybody. Everybody's got wise.
What drove I, you fought Trump. I'd worked trough. I fought everything I said,
it's who doesn't support the tropes? They're on our team.
But the brilliance is they've now morphed that into,
you cannot criticize the war if you do or anything that, that the, the, the,
the, the, the,
the head Pentagon is doing because now you're criticizing some 18 year old who's
over there fighting for your freedom. It's fucking brilliant.
And we should have seen this common with what happened to the saxophone in the
80s. All right. Girlfriends says, I'm stagnant. Oh,
Jesus. Oh Dude, that's a major red flag. Uh,
hey bill, you tiny Tim looking red nose. Pecker head. Okay.
Who is tiny Tim again. Oh,
tiny tips and ugly motherfucker with the Ukulele. Jesus Christ. Wow.
It looks like if somebody beat the shit out of George Washington.
Thank you for why that one really hurt. Ugh. Anyways, uh,
maybe I'll pull a Michael Jackson get a cleft in my chin. Uh, love you.
Love your podcast, but you wrote you love your podcast.
Even though I never get any advice. Uh, will you give me some?
I have l this is somebody who's not to use any punctuation.
This is all one sentence. Loved you po.
Maybe this person's foreign loved you podcast.
Even though I never get any advice. Will you give me some advice?
Will you give me some? I have this girlfriend I really like.
That's all one sentence. We worked together at the local restaurant.
I was fine until I got fired.
Then I got into a fight with my girlfriend's sister's boyfriend.
Got that? No, I don't. All right, let me,
let me try to break this down here.
Okay.
All right. You have this girlfriend you really like.
We work together at the local restaurant, I guess everything was cool.
And then you got fired and then you got into a fight with her? With hers.
Her sister.
Okay.
Her sister's boyfriend. Okay. So your girlfriend at work,
you've got new fight with her sister's boyfriend and then you got fired from the
TGI Friday's whatever the fuck you did. All right. I'm back on board.
Then I got a DWAI
driving while alcohol influenced, I dunno, I don't,
I know what the fuck's going on here. Um,
I F and I feel like a complete loser and sometimes it gets me depressed also.
I still give her rides to work,
which she tells me means nothing and also says she loves me,
but it's been getting meaner everyday. I don't get a job. All right,
well, okay,
well the defensive or you have to understand what the woman that if you're not
bringing in money, you just literally have,
you're like a 40 year old teenager at that point. You're just like a big kid.
She has to deal with, um, you know, and women,
they're all feminists until they have to start paying for everything.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like what's fucked up with sexism and all that and the guys have better paying
jobs. Evidently. I have no idea.
I've never asked people what the fuck they make,
but let's just say what they're saying is true. Um,
what's fucked up is,
is it now created this thing where women can date and like you're,
you're always for the most part, dating up.
You know, if you're,
if you have reasonable fucking looks okay and you had a reasonably good
childhood and for whatever, you're not migrating towards fucking losers.
All right?
You can actually always be in a situation where getting married is a good thing
cause the other person makes more money than you, so you don't have,
the whole fucking thing falls apart. You're going to get the house,
you're going to get the child support, you're going to get the alimony. Right.
Only lately are we finally starting to see women that having to do that and it's
fucking hell. Like they freak the fuck out. Like what
a woman paid alimony was. It's like I all of a sudden got my period, like, wait,
I gotta do this now. What the fuck? Right. Um, anyway,
so anyways, so let me get back to the fucking thing here. I, I keep,
I keep going on tangents here. I need to stay focused. Um, so, okay,
so you got a DUI, right. And she still gives me shit. Okay,
so now you're not making any money. So you know,
then you're all depressed and you don't have a car.
So I'm guessing you're not really looking for a fucking job or maybe she's just
meaning shit. I don't know. Anyways, he said,
I've never had trouble getting work when I needed it,
but now I feel like a lazy piece of Shit. My girlfriend called me stagnant,
stagnant, and told me she's worried. She said tonight,
she would see me later then changed it to,
or talk to you later and trailed off, muttering some inaudible bullshit.
I need to pay my rent tomorrow. Uh,
and I basically broke as fuck.
I gave her a key to my place and she agreed to pay half the rent,
but I feel like I'm twisting her arm to do it. Yeah, dude, what are you doing?
I feel stagnant to and depressed and she makes it hard to think sometimes.
So I secretly bought a train ticket to California,
so I secretly bought a train ticket to California from New York that leaves in
two weeks. I'm debating whether to stay here,
keep looking for a job in a debt economy.
Try and work things out with my girl. I'm sorry guys. Like this is not me here.
If this is how this is written in,
face the music by paying thousands of fines and traffic tickets while I'm broke
as fuck or go with the couple of hippie friends hikes through,
through like he threw a ball,
the state of California while stopping to work on wolfing farms in between
journeys. It's just like Jack Kerouac Shit. I don't know.
I'm starting to think this isn't real to stay or to go. I don't know.
But if she calls me stagnant again, I'll be out in over the horizon.
I feel bad and I don't know what the fuck to do. So any advice is appreciated.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Yeah. First of all, all right,
let's just eliminate the woman from all of this. Okay? Uh,
you need to pay a traffic tickets, dude,
if you think you're just going to walk away from that,
you're going to end up doing jail time.
A buddy of mine did that and K and they put them in county,
which you don't want to be in because that's all different levels of fucking
peoples. At least in La.
That's like rapist lunatics like their own kid on fire right down to a,
yeah, I had a bunch of traffic tickets and it got to such a f well made traffic
tickets. You know a traffic ticket. He had a DUI and he,
he didn't show up to court. Maybe you won't go to jail. I don't know.
But it's going to be a fucking nightmare and this can be hanging over your head
and then you're going to have to try to work under the table,
which is going to cause you not to fucking pay taxes.
It's going to be a nightmare. So, um,
okay.
I Dunno, I would, uh,
I would reach out for help is what I would do and I,
it doesn't sound like your girlfriend wants to do it anymore.
You haven't told me how long been unemployed,
but it sounds like she's at the brink of being fed up with you. But, uh,
you did get into a fight. You did get fired, you did drink and drive.
So you're making a bunch of bad moves and it's not her fault that she's trying
to envision a future with you.
And all she's seeing is that she's going to work while you're boozing it up and
she has to support you. And I'm going to go out on a limb here.
I don't like speaking for the ladies, but I'm going to go out on a limb and say,
I don't think a lot of women are looking for that in the future.
So I would man up.
You need the man to fuck up and realize that you are stagnant.
You need to get your shit together. All right.
I don't know what you have to do to find a fucking job.
That's a difficult thing. But um, I dunno.
Can you ask your parents for some help? Maybe you fucking leave your apartment,
move back in with your parents while you get through this.
You bought them the fuck out. You sober up.
You start working out with the old weights. You left in your parent's garage,
you find a fucking job. All right?
Get on a payment plan with you fucking tickets and all of that shit.
Get all of that off the table. Maybe even break up with your girlfriend.
Get your shit together, create a whole new fucking you.
And maybe you get a new girlfriend that's beyond the level of this one here that
was working at the fucking restaurant or whatever the hell you are at.
All right? But just know this. You sound like you're still young.
You got your whole life ahead of you and you know you're at.
What you're doing is you're giving into your situation rather than fucking
picking yourself up off the mat. All right, so get up off the floor.
Stop feeling sorry for yourself. All right?
You have all the power in the world to turn that thing around. All right. And a,
that's it. Get a job. Pay Off your tickets and uh, you know,
see what happens with that woman. You know, maybe she's not the one.
Maybe she is. Who knows who gives a fuck, but work on your life.
Work on yourself. There you go. All right. Girlfriends ultimatum and up.
Jesus Christ. Here we go again. Hey, Billy Bond.
My girlfriend, oh, parentheses of over one year recently gave me an ultimatum.
Weed or her? I chose weed. All right.
Here's a person who knows what he likes. Did you say that?
Did you say that in the moment? Did you wait a few days?
Did you mull it over for at least a few minutes?
Sick of your pot smoking. Okay. I know that, you know,
I said earlier that I was okay with it, but the truth is I'm not,
you're high all the time. I think it's affecting you and it's just, I,
I'm to the point, I can't do this anymore.
So you need to make a choice.
[inaudible]
you choose me or you choose marijuana.
Once I get to me, I'm gonna choose the weed sweetheart. See you.
She's going to slowly walk their head down out the fucking door.
It couldn't have gone down like that anyways. However, as I perceived it,
it was a choice of reason versus absurdity, not her verse.
We'd allow me to defend myself. Absolutely, Sir. You have the floor.
Um, or man, you know, this might be a lesbian relationship.
My girl and I started smoking together about two months ago.
She was never big on it, but I was a self-admitted pothead in the past.
We started smoking a couple of months ago and her request, uh,
we would smoke one or two hits per night before bed. Well,
last night she decided that she didn't like smoking weed anymore because she
doesn't like the feeling of being high. Apparently in that same moment,
she became morally opposed to the idea of marijuana and she proceeded to call me
an addict that has a serious problem in a grand dramatic gesture.
She flushed my remaining weed down the toilet and made me choose her or weed.
Wow. That escalated as they say an anchorman. Uh,
she kept pointing at me and [inaudible] yelling, look at yourself.
You're so high right now. Keep in mind,
I took one hit out of a one hitter.
I called bullshit on all of our arguments because as long as I've known her,
she has never had a problem with weed and would often encourage me to use it
because it does reduce my anxiety and temper.
She often brags about her ex boyfriend selling weed and her ex husband's smoking
every day and it not being an issue. All right.
I was kind of hearing her argument to those last fucking two sentences. Wow.
This person, this is a fucking retread year with, Huh? Jesus. A,
you got her onto the recycle bin there. I as soy assumed this wasn't about weed,
but something else. I assume it's the result of me telling her months ago, oh,
here we go.
That I wouldn't be with her if she continued to drink because she had a serious,
seriously unhealthy relationship with alcohol. So,
I imagine she's trying to use this as her chance to play holier than thou card
for the record. I don't want to smoke weed all day slash every day.
It's the principle of the thing.
But now my relationship is riding on this thing and I don't want,
I don't want to do what is riding on this thing and I don't want to do,
I think it's riding on this thing that you don't want to do is stick what you're
trying to say. What are your thoughts? Help a brother out.
Do I want to deal with this crazy level of hypocrisy forever. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um, I don't think so. No,
I don't think so. Uh, and they detached away that you're able to talk about her.
And you never once said that, you know, I really love her though.
You never said that. So, um,
it sounds like she had a rough childhood that led into alcohol abuse and to her,
uh, picking some really fucking, so we're a winners here.
Drug dealers and fucking, uh, I don't know Mike.
I don't know what her ex husband did, but he smoked every day. Um,
yeah, I, I think, uh,
okay.
The way you tell it, it doesn't sound like a rational person. So, um,
on the other side,
I will tell you there are a lot of people that get high every day and don't
think that they have a problem. Whereas if you get drunk every day,
people call you a drunk and say, you know, you have a problem. Um,
I have a couple friends of mine that did that for a good 20 fucking years and
they paid the price.
I'm smoking weed every single fucking day. It's like everything.
He wouldn't want to eat ice cream every day. You'd be a fat fuck.
You drink booze every day. You're going to have a bad liver, gallbladder, gin,
blossoming. Fucking alcohol is brutal. And I actually, you know,
now that I've finally been educated a little bit on weed,
I really do believe it's way, way worse.
It definitely ages you way, way, way more, um, than we does.
But I don't think like, you know,
wake and bake people and people who need weed to fall asleep.
I know it helps with anxiety and shit like that. And obviously, you know,
pain of chemotherapy, it's got a lot of great things. But I,
I wouldn't really comes down to is if it's not,
if you feel it's not affecting your life,
then I would just continue to do what you're doing.
But it's something that as an adult, you know, when you move out,
your parents aren't there to fucking question your behavior. You really have to,
I feel be extra tough on yourself. Like I drank way too much last year,
way too fucking much.
So I'm glad that I kind of have it back under control and even,
I probably drank way too much. Um,
so I'm trying to look at that type of shit and you know, it's funny when I,
when I don't drink, you know,
I'm more apt to take a hit a weed because I'm just used to having a little bit
of a buzz every couple of days.
So then I that always whenever I quit drinking,
then there'll be like a two week period that if somebody has weed, hey,
you want to hit, I'll actually take a hit and I'd never smoke weed.
But then after that, then I, then I just, you know, I just don't like weed.
I'm just not into it. And um,
then after like two weeks, then I just kinda just don't do anything.
And then that's when I start getting into shape again. So whatever, I think,
you know, you sound pretty level headed and you never said you love there.
So I would get out of that. That sounds like a fucking,
you'd really have to like demand a baggage. She sounds like she has, you know.
Yeah.
Me marrying a fucking alcoholic. I mean that just, that,
that really takes a fucking saint t is if you're sober, sort of,
I don't know. I don't know why you'd want to put yourself through that.
All right. That's their issue to fucking deal with.
And you gotta be selfish when you want to find the right person.
So there you go. Alright. Older lady wants to bang.
No, JJ, here's to you,
Mrs. Robertson. Alright. Hey Bill.
I am a 22 year old senior at college just outside of Baltimore and I'm a big fan
of your stand up a podcast. Well thank you.
I caught your show when he came to Baltimore and you absolutely killed it.
Thank you again. Anyways, I wanted to,
I wanted your advice as it relates to an older fucking lady.
Um, so just to give you a little background,
last summer I decided to get in shape.
I developed a nice workout routine and subsequently lost 40 pounds and really
built up some muscle. As a result, women have been showing me a lot more,
showing a lot more interest in me. They had go turned it around. Good for you.
I'm happy for you and I have definitely had more confidence with talking to
women. All right, we'll keep going. Keep going,
keep going and keep shooting for the moon.
Talk to those chicks you think around to the audio leak, see what happens.
Anyways.
Now I have been using some dating apps and have met and hooked up with more
women than I have ever have before. Not Bragging. It's just the facts.
All right, well I be using a condom. They're fucking Studley. Um,
so recently, and this may sound weird,
I ran across this incredibly attractive 50 year old woman on one of the dating
apps and liked your profile. Just kind of as a joke. No,
you didn't. You were attracted to it. It gives a shit.
She is a classic example of a cougar.
She's like Mrs. Robinson from the graduate or that horny bitch from sex in the
city who just fucks everybody. Oh my God. Yeah.
The most one dimensional character ever. Kim Cottrell's character.
It's just fucking with every fucking line. It's like, I get it.
You fuck a lot of guys. Has anybody ever just,
there has to be a youtube video where everybody just put all those lines from
the entire fucking series. It's like,
okay,
my, my knee.
I used to watch the thing and all the way back when it was on when we were still
living in New York, we were living together in this apartment.
I would just be on the other side of the apartment.
She'd be watching it at any time. Kim Cottrell's character would say something.
I would always be in the background. I would just go cause she's a whore.
Um, anyways, he says, much to my surprise, I matched with her.
I don't know what that means. She hit you back basically.
She's surprisingly sexually aggressive.
It isn't women fucking by their mid thirties. They know what the fuck they want.
They don't give a shit anymore and clearly wants to fuck me.
She sends me messages all the time and talks about how she likes younger men.
Of course she does. She does want to bang some fucking old bastard like me.
She followed me on snapchat recently and started sending me nude pictures and
shit. He Blake now,
at least in my experience, young guys always joke about the of fucking a cougar.
All my friends are saying I should just fuck her,
but I can't shake the feeling that there's something fucked up about it.
Is it weird that she's over twice my age? What are your thoughts on this bill?
Should I fucker or is it a bad idea? Let me know. Thanks to go fuck yourself.
Oh Sir. This is going to be a great lesson for you. Um,
how old did you say you were? 22. Okay.
I will tell you this and it took me into my early forties to learn this.
There is no way to ever over emphasize the importance of listening to your gut.
Listening to your gut will will.
I'm telling you when your gut just tells you, man, this doesn't feel right.
You fucking walk away.
Walk away every fucking time, okay? Unless it's like,
it's something that, you know, it's some sort of stage fright thing,
some sort of anxiety thing that you have to get over.
You're not afraid of fucking women. Okay?
Now all of a sudden this woman's coming and this is fucking failing that you
fail and this ain't right to just fucking walk, walk,
walk away. Okay.
What kind of a fucking 50 year old is sending naked pictures to somebody have to
fucking age. All right. Now I know this day of hyper feminism,
they'll say that that's actually brave. It's this. It's that. It's empowering.
It's fucking pathetic because all you have to do is slide it over.
If a guy was sending Dick pics to a 22 year old chick,
see what I'm saying? You know what I mean? This is like
whatever. Anyways, yeah dude, fucking walk away. That's, you know,
that's a fucking train wreck and your gut is telling you that and you need to
just listen to your gut. All right?
When you go into a job interview and you fucking sit in across from the person
they're talking to you, I'm telling you beyond just interview,
you're going to get a sense. I swear to God,
I took a meeting one time with somebody, and the second I met this person,
I just didn't like them. And there was something about them.
They felt sleazy and I got this joke, thief vibe from them,
and I immediately stopped telling stories and all that shit.
And I ended up going and I just was like, wow.
I thought I really wanted to meet that person.
Then I met them and they weren't what I thought they were going to be.
And then I talked to like two or three people about them. They like, yeah,
that guy's got a, he's got a fucking rep for steel and shit. I'm telling you,
you gotta listen to your gut. It will give up. That's how you, how you end up,
not in the trunk of a serial killer's car. Is your guts going to tell, hey,
you know, I don't give a fuck if this person has a flat keep driving.
You're going to feel it. You're going to feel that weird thing. So good feel.
Don't do it. All right, here we go. All right, let's read the last thing here.
Overrated. Underrated. Uh, Hey,
you Bruin love and Fuck Boston Bruin love and fuck actually get it right.
The original Bruins. I like the UCLA Bruins who came later. Um,
overrated.
Sidney Crosby is the most overrated comment I can think of. Oh,
give me a fucking break, dude. All right.
So he scored a lot of goals against your team, is what I'm guessing. Anyways.
He said,
I wished this Cox cocksucker would be held accountable for just one of the
ridiculous fucking antics.
He Poles this bag of shit most recently jams is sticking to Ryan O'Reilly's nuts
from behind. You can see in the replay,
he waits for the ref to be screened and assassinates O'Reilly's future kids.
He won't even get a fine fuck him. And every comment that routes forum,
um, I understand that, I understand that. But you know,
Lucci choose to play for us and he was the king of spear and people in the taint
and the nuts. Um, I dunno,
I would just, you know,
he also makes the league a lot of money and superstars have different rules.
That's just how it is. But I will tell you this,
that guy's backhander is fucking f has more power in speed to it than a lot of
guys. Wrist is in the league, the best backhand I've ever seen. And um,
you know, I have to give it up to greatness, but you know, he, yeah, he,
he used to whine a lot when he was younger.
I think half of it was his pouty lips, so it made it look even worse. But uh,
I don't know that guy's a stud man, but I understand not liking them. Um,
anyways, underrated bowling.
I recently found out I have a spine problem. I spine problems.
So I had to quit softball and flag football.
The good thing I was at high school. Uh, the,
I was good at I guess the sport.
I was good at a lot of people fucking up this week. The sport, the sports.
I was good at high school in high school,
but not that good starter kit.
You left out a couple of words and that thing buddy. Anyways,
my brother turned me on to bowling leagues and it's way better than I ever gave
it credit for. It's competitive. You win a little money and if you suck ass,
you can walk 10 feet to the bar and get lit slash win-win.
Thanks. Go Fuck Yourself. Absolutely. Bowling's the shit.
Um, but I will tell you, uh, I would definitely go to a chiropractor and, uh,
I would get a great misuse and maybe they can work out a lot of your back stuff
because, uh, you know,
if you're going to go from active shit to something inactive like that and add
alcohol, you're going to put on weight, which is not going to be good for you.
Certainly your lower back.
You can be walking around like you're in your third trimester and you'd never
given birth. You know what I mean?
Terminal pregnancy of fucking booze and pizza.
All right, everybody, that is the, um, Fezza podcast for this week.
All right? Always listen to your gut.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday. Gulf Bruins.
Go Celtics. Go fuck yourselves.